Candid Truth.
>> Hi everybody. Welcome back. We are going
to talk about this mainly because I've
gotten so many questions and I really,
believe me, I don't want to cover this,
but we're going to have to. And if you
haven't already realized
been around kids, excuse me, who are
just out and about or on social media,
you've noticed this is a trend that is
happening right now.
and we're going to find out where that
is coming from. Let's take a look real
quick.
So, this comes from um a rapper
named Skrilla and his song called Doot
Doot. And this kid, we're going to see
the kid um a little bit further who was
found creating this catchphrase 67. And
so let's take a look at this.
All right. So here's the kid and what he
did to make it popular.
67.
[cheering]
>> Okay, so he kept doing that. Somehow it
caught on. It's just
really weird. But now we're going to go
to the part of the song where
he says that so we know where it comes
from.
assa
shades on with the glasses bro say cuz
he a savage so many dead so many ashes
you ain't catch that I can't pass this
shoo I don't need mine bro they behind
that I know he
>> all right so [sighs and gasps] that's
where it comes from. So this guy wrote
the song and it took off in a overnight
way just went viral because of this kid.
And what we're going to find out is that
this guy Skrilla, first of all, I hate
to say it, but he's such a poor rapper
that half of his lyrics don't even have
anything real to be spoken of, and
nothing's really going on in the song.
So, he actually admitted and we're we'll
see a video in just a minute also. Um,
maybe I shouldn't pop this yet for you
guys. Let me just let you see it.
So, this is what he says that he
believes in and what he kind of used.
[snorts]
>> You You mentioned your religion. [sighs]
>> What What religion exactly do you
represent?
>> I'm a Santo. I do Paulo. [music]
though.
>> What's that mean exactly?
>> All that sacrificing goats and all that
not just for like that's that's real
life. You're
>> You sacrificed a goat.
>> You seen that, bro? That's real life,
bro. I sacrifice goats, chickens, mice.
Like I do for certain, though. Like, I'm
not allowed to explain it. How you want
me to explain it? I think how you want
me to explain it. But yeah,
>> I can do my research. That's
interesting.
>> It ain't even going You're not even
going to find it like Google. You could
Google it, but it ain't going to
explain. It's it's like a it's it's You
could try to do your research though and
let me know what you find out though,
bro.
>> Okay. So, that is what we have. He
admits it right there that he is into
Santaia and Paulo Mayome is what it's
called. And we know then that he is a
practitioner. He actually practices it
in his life.
But then nothing about those two things
are neutral at all. in a
religious from a religious standpoint,
they're always charged with energy and
satanic energy.
And it's used very much so just like in
the Luciferian systems for ancestry.
It's rooted in ancestry and culture and
false light.
So in Palameon Bay, spirits of the dead
are summoned and housed in iron
cauldrons called nangas.
In Santaia, the pagan saints are really
rebranded African deities merged with
cath with Catholic imagery to hide them
from colonizers. So these systems are
entirely demonic in origin and in
practice and in outcome.
So let's not mince words at all. Let's
just talk about it the way that it is.
Palamebe is one of the darkest
bloodbased spiritbinding rituals on
earth.
And when someone says that they are
Santo Santo, they are either initiated
or spiritually bound to these deities
which are actually demons. And because
well, he doesn't seem to have much going
for him as a rapper a lot.
He's using this to to climb up the
ranks. It's all about the spells and the
castings and the rituals and sacrifices
that he's doing to get somewhere in
life.
So, when we're actually talking about
this,
it says the chant 67 is absolutely not
innocent at all. and not random. Here's
why. I'll tell you. It's really
interesting. The code
in police reports, let me show you. Let
me show you. This
is not random at all. It's actually a
code. So, here's the book I got it from
online police reports.
Next page. It is to report a death.
Doot also from the name's title is the
name of a the it actually means to shoot
a gun.
So everything about this song is
shouting a cult structure in numerology
and AfroCaribbean
rights.
Numbers are divine signatures actually.
And six and seven are commonly
associated as you saw on that video
where he was talking about what he
believes in and they were showing some
of the gods that he a very slight um
short time that they showed a god that
he sacrifices to named
uh
or Ishu and Ogan or Chant Chango.
Um,
so we're going to take a look at that
because these gods
man
they are there you go. So you know how
to name
the names are spelled Alangua
Oen Lucerno Mundo which is Paulo. These
are
starting with alongua is a spirit of
crossroads and chaos. We have seen or
heard about that before when we talk
about
um
a lot of other
musicians have done the whole crossroads
thing. They've sold their soul. They've
gone through all of that with the devil
and they have come back with some skills
usually.
So that's one god. Then you have Oen or
Chango, which is the god of war,
domination, and masculine fire. Lucero
Mundo is the gatekeeper demon who opens
portals. These numbers are called out in
chance to summon, activate, or attract
specific spirits. So when it really
comes all together,
we have
Skrilla.
We have Skrilla. this rapper melding six
and seven to represent two of his spirit
gods
and then the chant is spiritually
binding. So he made it a spiritually
binding spell.
So every time kids are shouting in the
video or listening to it in a loop or
you hear them just doing it, they're
unknowingly participating in a mass
invocation ritual is what he has
created.
This has happened several times. We've
seen it when Beyonce embedded Orisha
possession when DOA Cat used sigils and
when Travis Scott had stages with mass
energy sacrifices happening, people just
dying left and right.
Skrilla 67 is coded energetic gateways
of Satan that hides in the sound, in the
rhythm and repetition as always.
So when you do the binding spell and you
charge I guess the word 67
which means I guess he asked the spirits
to take that number when he says it in
the song and charge it with that kind of
spell. Um
he opened a demonic portal
and it targeted children specifically.
So this portal
can be understood because it's a
meaningless thing to the speaker and to
the people who are listening. It really
doesn't make sense. That shows that it's
a totally kind of blackmagic thing
that's happening. It's spiritually
significant to the initiator to him. He
knows what happened and it's widely
repeated without discernment with the
kids or use of one's brain.
It's attached to a known practitioner of
Paulo and Santaia. So all these facts
make it hard to ignore the fact that he
did use it as a spell.
It's digital ritual that he he's
spreading across the world. It was no
accident at all. As you guys can see,
the numbers were selected specifically
for those gods. They were charged and
released to go viral.
And the thing is, most of us don't know
what's going on. It is some kind of
meaningless thing. And our kids are
walking around chanting code phrases
that are for demon portals to be opened.
The parents around us, especially if
you're trying to be a Christian parent,
we don't know what's going on. We're
playing worship music in the background
of our car or our house, thinking that
this will kind of trump or cancel out
what is happening to help our kids get
over it. But the enemy is laughing, I
believe, because the access has been
granted through that gateway.
As I've said before, if you just
realized and went and watched my other
um video on frequency, magic, and
control within music, please go watch
that because it kind of talks about
this. The where I'm going to go right
now is that sound is actually
spiritually used. And they understand
this. They actually understand
Luciferian occult ways of using sound.
that vibration is ritual for them,
repetition is permission,
and participation is actually a covenant
you're making with the demons or
spirits.
So, Skrilla is being a conscious vessel.
We know this.
And it brings us to the fact that we
first of all, I want you guys to see
what these gods even look like.
They're kind of [sighs]
totally ridiculous. A lot of shell eyes,
nose, and lips, and just a clump of
clay.
If you notice how much they sell for, it
is ridiculous as well. This is nothing,
you guys. It's a god
who knows nothing, who is nothing. It
cannot do anything. thing. The thing is
is when you call upon the spirits or
Satan to possess something like that, he
can do that. That is where the power,
the bad power really lies. But God is
greater than all of these. Let's go back
and see the other gods that he actually
called upon to charge this chant.
This actually, let's go back one. This
was the first one. Alugua or Ashua. I
mean ish issue. So that was the first
god that's for the number six.
And then this was the second god Orisha
or oen and chongo. I don't know why they
have so many extra names but this one
was for the number seven.
This one is Lucero Mundo, which actually
means
the bright star, I believe, and morning
star. You can tell that this one has, of
course, the same kind of um ridiculous
shell eyes, but much more of a mean face
and seems to always have a horn, excuse
me, a horn type top on its head. Um, I
think the red might be from sacrifices
being put on it,
but this is just
it's so wrong. It's so ridiculous. But
Satan knows how to deceive and get
people doing these things.
And he knows that Tik Tok and Instagram
and social media is where your kids are
at. So he used that pathway
through Skrilla. Satan used that pathway
through Skrilla to do this spell that's
cast a mass ritual invocation.
So let's let's be honest though because
I know someone's going to ask someone is
going to ask so are the numbers six and
seven evil right on their own. Of course
we know that it wasn't. Um those numbers
exist in every culture, every language.
And biblically, of course, God had day
1, day 2, day three, day four, day, you
know, day five, 6 and 7. And so,
it's just strange because God created
numbers basically.
Um, and like all of creation, they are
not evil in themselves.
But just like a knife or a trumpet or a
piece of wood, they can be used for holy
or unholy purposes.
So when do numbers become spiritually
dangerous? Only when they are used
spiritually to be charged with an intent
with gods or demonic forces such as a
spell
or a hex. When they're used
ritualistically in repetition, rhythm,
and incantation.
when they're disconnected from knowledge
or submission to God because people are
doing it almost without even thinking.
They're just saying it because it's
cool, quote unquote cool. It's used in a
system designed to invoke when there
when numbers are used in a system to
invoke, influence, or initiate spiritual
power. It's also dangerous
because it's not really a number at that
point. If you understand, it's a binding
um
spell placed on on the user who uses it.
So, [sighs]
everyday use of the number six and seven
is safe. biblical context of use of it
is safe with homework, of course, with
everyday stuff, but used in a ritual or
chant or used with it being tied to gods
or spirits. Of course not. You guys know
this. You just need to use common sense.
But
yes,
>> I'm almost done.
>> So,
there were some comments in here. Thank
you guys so much for always adding and
contributing.
>> I want to scroll and put the comment on
screen because uh I think you guys
should get the props for this
>> and and you guys, you know, you always
help us with our research when you reach
out to us and say, "Hey, have you heard
of this or look into this right here?"
Um Marco said, "Yeah, he has an album
called Sixes and Sevens." It's crazy.
So, there was a rapper I used to listen
to named Tech9. Haven't listened to him
in years. So, I was not aware of this.
But, let me pull up the website right
here. And I was just looking it up. I
can't [clears throat] believe it. This
is This is for real.
So, all these musicians, they're all
sold out. And Tech 9, you know, I even
looked up what religion is he and he
proclaims to be a Christian, ironically.
But check this out.
Tech [clears throat] nine,
sixes and sevens.
Look what you find here.
>> I wish this had the the same. Here we
go. All sixes and all sevens.
>> Yeah,
>> all six and and all sevens. The 11th
studio album. 11 is a cult number, too.
>> I believe
>> they're not seeing it. Oh, no. Sorry.
>> Sorry, guys. Let's try that again real
quick.
>> Let's make sure we got this. No,
this one. No, no, no. Okay, hold on,
guys. I think we got it.
>> There we go.
>> All right. Um,
got to get in here. Okay,
>> so this is Tech9's album, All Sixes and
Sevens.
And notice right here when it came out,
interestingly enough, right here, see
this box? It says June 7th, 2011. June
is the sixth month. 7 is the seventh
day. 2011. 11 is an occult. Number two.
None of this is by accident. 911. All
that kind of stuff. This coming out on
67 and being called all sixes. All
seven. No coincidence. All sixes uh and
sevens is the 11th album. So his 11th
album, he titled it six and seven. Came
out on 6711.
not a coincidence. Like to even believe
it was is a coincidence is insane.
Um and so I looked up
I [clears throat] looked him up
satanic
tech 9
and this dude he's he's blatant [snorts]
about who he serves. Look at this. He's
got devil horns. I remember this album
called Angelic. He's got a the anarchy
symbol on his face and he's he's painted
like a skull.
He's got a nine on his forehead because
he's called Take Nine. But there was a
picture, if I can find it, you know,
he's got the dragon on his forehead. Um
he he's all about this dragon. That's
his logo. It's usually a red dragon.
He's dressed like a Catholic priest
here.
>> Wow.
>> Um he's throwing up the horns, you see.
And his colors are when I looked it up.
What are his colors? I want to find this
picture first, though. I can't believe
I'm not seeing it now cuz I just saw it
on my phone. He had 67 carved on his
chest. Oh, where is that?
>> What?
>> Wait, man. Let me see if I can find it.
Um,
[snorts]
uh, he had 67 carved on his chest. Where
is it? I just had it on my phone.
Let's see.
>> Wow. I can't believe it.
Um,
okay. Well, check this out. We looked at
that. So, we looked at the um you showed
those gods and the colors.
>> Yeah.
>> Tech 9 colors.
His colors are red and black. When you
look it up,
>> um what are Tech 9's colors can refer to
his brand or range of colors? Black,
red, and white.
>> Black, red, and white are his colors.
Just like the the colors that were on
those gods. Black and red, satanic
colors.
>> But I got to find this picture. Okay,
I'm gonna go back real quick because I
want to talk to you guys
for a minute.
So, what I found interesting about Mikey
bringing this up is that they're both
this guy that Mikey's bringing up and
Skrilla are not only into different
colors or into um painting their face.
If you saw, they both wear masks at
times and he has some really terrible
looking masks
>> and they're not like they're always kind
of wearing a costume almost wrapping
their head. It's always their head being
a someone
and a mask. And so that seems to be a
thing related to Palame and um Santa
Santo a lot because they have to put on
African masks usually to invoke these
demons also from ancestry and other
cultures. And so I'm just going to leave
that there. But that's the connection
I'm seeing as well.
>> Okay, I found I found the picture.
Um,
so take nine.
This says the
line up. I thank you guys for your
patience with all this. We'll edit this
stuff out tomorrow when we can.
>> Mhm.
>> 20
best lines
of 2011.
Look at this.
>> Okay.
>> 67 on his chest with the word sacrifice
on his chest. Are you kidding me?
Sacrifice 67. He's got the red light on
him. Look. Six on his arm. Six on his or
seven on his other arm. This is not
coincidence, man. Like this is crazy.
This was 2011.
>> 2011.
>> Yeah. This is
>> said Wendy's is jumping on Wendy's is
jumping on the 67.
>> Oh no. You know. Yeah. So that is it in
a nutshell. It's just it's not benign at
all. It is actually what like Taylor
Swift did in her last song. It wasn't
very talent. She wasn't very talented in
that one either. But she has charged it.
Also, if you haven't realized, a lot of
the magicians
today that we're seeing are actually
musicians. They are the music artists of
today that use spells against you to
want to listen to the music, sing to it,
be overtaken by it. Again, if you
haven't watched that one on frequency
magic or sorcery, that was that was it.
Frequency sorcery that I last did just a
bit ago. Please go watch that. It
explains how all of that um technically
works and how they use it, their
methodology even in the industry. So
that is it. I hope you guys are clear on
that now and understand. I hope your
children are not doing this. Um and that
they can know the truth of what is
happening. Um, we need discernment and
time is coming short. And I hope also
that we know that we are not supposed to
be worshiping as the heathens do with
their gods
and that when we do know that it's
happening, we are to expose them. So,
thank you guys so much for your support.
Um, you guys can go ahead and use these
links to support us further if you'd
like to donate.
We have merchandise of course on our
website that's candidtruth.org.
And thank you guys
for tuning in. I I'm so glad to have you
guys and we love you. Bye.